digamos que vamos a lanzar un objeto
hacia el aire con un cierto ángulo y
digamos que su rapidez es ese
estamos lanzando un objeto en el aire su
rapidez va a ser ese y le vamos a lanzar
con cierto ángulo al que vamos a llamar
teta
lo que quiero en este vídeo es calcular
qué tan lejos llegará este objeto en
función de su ángulo y también en
función de su rapidez aunque voy a
suponer que conozco este dato de la
velocidad que es como una constante
entonces se pueden imaginar
que estamos lanzando el objeto
sobre el suelo y que este objeto va a
seguir una trayectoria parabólica
y va a caer en algún punto por acá
entonces tengo aquí mi distancia cero
y aquí me distancia de
cuando tengo que resolver algún problema
como este de lanzar un objeto con cierto
ángulo y lo mejor es comenzar
descomponiendo el vector recuerden que
el vector es algo que tiene una magnitud
y una dirección en este caso en la
magnitud es ese la rapidez y en la
dirección no la síndica el ángulo theta
así es que si tienen s y theta tienen un
vector lo que tienen que hacer es
descomponer este vector en sus
componentes
la componente horizontal y la componente
vertical y trabajar con ellos de manera
independiente
1 les va a ayudar a saber cuánto tiempo
duraron en el aire o duro su proyectil
en el aire y otro les va a ayudar a
calcular qué tan lejos lanzaron este
objeto
entonces vamos a dibujar un poquito más
grande este vector
tenemos entonces
esta es la dirección de nuestro objeto
esta es la magnitud de su velocidad la
rapidez es e íbamos a
trabajar o dibujar con verde
la componente
vertical
y con otro color
nuestra componente horizontal aquí lo
que vamos a hacer para descomponer los
elementos de este ángulo perdón de este
vector es
formar un triángulo rectángulo de éste
ese es nuestro ángulo rectángulo de 90
grados formamos este triángulo
rectángulo y vamos a usar nuestras
fórmulas trigonométricas básicas para
calcular la magnitud de este vector y de
este otro vector
entonces vamos a llamar a la magnitud de
nuestro componente vertical
la velocidad
vertical pero la rapidez en su
componente vertical y aquí va a ser
nuestra componente de velocidad
sentido horizontal
vamos a usar el término velocidad cuando
se especifica la magnitud y la dirección
y aquí estoy refiriéndome a s como
rapidez indicando que es solo la
magnitud de la velocidad bueno para
calcular esto vamos a usar nuestras
fórmulas trigonométricas entonces vamos
a escribir aquí nuestras fórmulas o
nuestras funciones trigonométricas
básicas que sólo seno
jose no
y tangente recordamos que el seno es el
cateto opuesto de nuestro ángulo sobre
la hipotenusa el coche no es el cateto
adyacente entre la hipotenusa y la
tangente es el cateto opuesto entre el
cateto adolescente y bueno vamos a ver
que podemos decir con esto asumimos que
conocemos ese y conocemos el ángulo teta
vamos a calcular la componente vertical
y la componente horizontal puede ser el
componente vertical bueno de nuestras
fórmulas trigonométricas vemos que este
el seno es el que involucra el cateto
opuesto
sobre la hipotenusa entonces tendremos
que el pse no tenemos escribirlo de
color verde que es el color que estamos
usando para el componente vertical
el seno de nuestro ángulo theta es igual
al cateto opuesto que en este caso es
nuestra velocidad de nuestra rapidez
vertical
entre la hipotenusa que es nuestra
velocidad del vector
lo que nos interesa es conocer el
componente vertical entonces vamos a
despejar lo multiplicando ambos lados
por ese y nos quedará que ese por el
seno de teta es igual a nuestra
componente vertical
entonces lo escribimos nuestro
componente vertical es igual a ese por
el seno de teta
y ahora hacemos lo mismo con nuestro
componente horizontal en este caso
trabajamos con este color
ok y cuál es la función que nos va a ser
útil tenemos que este es el elemento que
queremos conocer y la función
trigonométricas que nos le involucrase
el consell o porque es el cateto
adyacente sobre la hipotenusa entonces
tenemos que conocerlo del ángulo teta es
igual ahora nuestra componente
horizontal
entre la velocidad del vector de la
misma manera despejamos y nos va a
quedar s por q se lo detecta es igual a
ese h lo escribimos aquí en nuestro
componente horizontal es igual a
ese por joselo de t
ahora sabemos qué tan rápido estamos
viajando en esta dirección en nuestro
componente
horizontal
y también bueno también conocemos la
velocidad en nuestro componente vertical
ya tenemos descompuestos ya tenemos los
compuestos nuestro factor en sus
componentes y ahora estamos listos para
calcular cuánto tiempo estará en nuestro
proyecto en el aire